we'll take five suggestions we'll kind
of divide the room up into quarters then
we'll take a wild card at the answer
come to this segment first what you guys
want to hear a rap about lost library
books thank you very much one person
just did one clap there are you a fellow
yet three people loving this lost
library books I like that's a very good
suggestion middle row right in front of
me what you guys want to rap about
communism Wow
now it's a pretty it's a pretty big
subject isn't it so do you want to pick
a specific aspect of communism we can
really delve into I mean I mean I guess
that kind of comes with the territory I
mean obviously we could have we couldn't
take in like you know what what type of
communism Flags the Communist flag
okay cool communist and specifically
Flags lost library books this section of
the middle here what you guys gonna
suggest there were two photosynthesis
surprising to get shout out all the time
I don't know why but you can you can
check I promise you there's a video
online if someone's just not and I did
take if I don't take the same
suggestions twice because I would be
cheating I promise you what was that
what 8 mile okay I get it cuz Eminem
that works
tell you what we'll combine it 8 mile
photosynthesis that'll be two that feels
fair a mile first sense this communism
and flags and lost library books you
guys this is your time to shine what's
it gonna be so a two so you said hiking
to the more Gaza
[Applause]
don't point at me that's scary that's
like a and you're next come on we're
hiking and just what what did you say
video games hiking to the morgue is more
exciting I'm sorry
hiking to the morgue eight-mile
photosynthesis Communist flags and lost
library books let's take one final one
let's let's make this from anywhere and
it has to be the best one gonorrhea no
people think it's fun to shower out what
was that Observatory I'm gonna combine
it gonorrhea Observatory thank you I
knew I was gonna take that gonorrhea
observatory hiking to the Lord lost
library books communism Flags and eight
mile photosynthesis you might need to
remember these come won't forget them
lovely people of Hermosa Beach this is a
little treat for you guys little thing
called a freestyle rap
that is a rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions it's not
written it's not rehearse it will never
be performed again and do not worry it
will not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you are all
expecting a twenty nine-year-old
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be one drop that beat I'm so
excited it's gonna be great
gonorrhea Observatory hiking to the
morgue a mile first census communist
flags and lost library books let's do
this
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah when my mind starts to Sag adjust
things back a Russia discuss Communist
flags they have the big red back with
the hammer and the sickle slightly off
top left yeah never in the middle now
they moved on they went from the CCP put
the white blue and red stripes that was
three it's a trio I don't know which
order it's in probably blue white red
but communism still possesses the way
that they run the government you have
all the countries with it not pleasant
go down to Cuba although the medical
system is great Fidel Castro for some
reason you all hey anyway we'll move on
yeah I might feel fear who the flexing
love for that man with cigars and the
beard next thing you know I'll never let
you off the hook I'm gonna say I find
you for the library book that you lost
I'm the boss at this library
I'm a scary man librarian is plain to
see if you come in with the bag Ernest
missing the hardback I will say you give
you a heart kicking out of the back of
the library this runs on public funding
you should remember don't lose them to
the understanding that we had when it
gave you as card you have to sign it if
you've lost a book yeah I hope you damn
find it maybe go and buy a new one from
the bookstore come back again I'll break
your damn good jaw yeah you've got good
chins I'm not saying that I'll break it
though
next thing lion like Pinocchio I'd live
with the smile if I said I hated
eight-mile I love that stuff I admire
Eminem style
he was like you gotta lose yourself but
if you in you garden a new tree has got
low health you need to make sure you
water it and get the sunlight and feed
it with the oxygen and then the trees
right it's happy sorry not the oxygen I
mean the carbon co2 a mile length of my
garden buck
we say Imperial eight-mile in the UK 12
kilometers y'all that's the difference
we translate across the ocean
next in I've got to apply lotion for
this burning half right around in
perhaps it what time I was fighting in
France that like a world war ii soldier
coming over here having sex with every
french lady catching gonorrhea i come
back the doctor looks at me and says you
need to go in the gonorrhea observatory
observatory like you look in that the
photosynthesis when I feel this light
burn when I piss I go doctor please give
me the antibiotic I need them right now
they're too expensive to jot it down in
their prescription so we watch his war
from a safe distance with by Nakia laws
he looks at me says Wow Brit I can tell
it's infectious look at that large
gonorrhea swell it's so damn big I hate
the smell so I run away but then I die
I'm not well so he picks me up yeah
takes a sword trophy into bits and puts
me in a bag heads to the morgue puts me
in a black pack puts it on his spine and
says Chris yeah I'm saving your time he
puts me in one of those weird silver
trays you see it in CSI these days on TV
but I'm quite astute I've never seen the
actors in that wearing hiking boots
presumably they get there by car they're
not walking up the valley I'm over there
well understand me people start to talk
and say this is mind blowing ate more
photosynthesis that's how high the trees
are growing there you go
you